I like a lady that's like it's like I
don't know this is maybe gross but like
if she worked out like five hours ago
and didn't shower Chris we're in this is
what I'm talking about this is why this
show exists is to have this conversation
conversations like this I'm completely
with you if the way a girl smells okay
good I'm with ya is bad to you right
that's a pheromone yes sign but don't
come out damn you know it's not okay you
somebody else might really like that
like a phrase a French guy would
probably like that or yeah - you and
your chemistry she smells great -
someone else it might smell like a
seagull I get it and guess what if you
have sex with a girl like that and have
a kid it'll be a bad kid have you ever
smelled yourself and million little
girls I'm always like so great it's all
right
it smells like an Italian deli but I
like it too can I even say even when
you're going to number two you're like I
like you but you're kind of like you
could pick your own fart out of a lineup
always next to a woman that was eating a
burrito in the movies which is a bad
choice do they sell them at the purchase
you put in a purse this woman you
smuggle this smell that's not a lot
everybody could smell it right but then
she ate it and then you couldn't smell
it anymore but that's weird because the
burritos still in there s it's it's just
in a human cool and you know like during
the third act of prisoners or whatever
you're watching you're gonna get a
little bit
the fridge and you got a little bad cold
we and and then you and then you just
because you know it's coming and then
you start this mugging and you're like
no you cut out to the world it no voices
because I just love your British so much
can you teach me how to do a bet
alright you think I'm being completely
serious you got a great British accent I
think you're being nice there sometimes
British people will be like you know
that's that you really it's really good
you got it you know I think I think
being nice you know you know I can't do
it I can't do it not like that although
just oh it's less of a face thing though
you're just going I might like I choose
yeah love you special Frank will go down
two times fine thanks thanks thanks
points
no well if you're talking about tanks
actual tanks like a few diving in that
you know not shoot people chick who's
not big cannons a while yeah you know
it's a good size that's why you know
they they would never call it a penis I
never make up a name for it bangers and
mash
yeah what are you talking about my willy
my bits and pieces long Greg Kenya
whatever
it's my c'mere c'mere you want my career
and your ear deer and all of a sudden
British rap this is so funny you're one
of the funniest people I know like was
me thanks for being here miss Julia or
his drag act crystal Lea
[Applause]
[Music]